وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قولها ان قوتها دمرت
طائرات مسيره اوكرانيه فوق البحر الاسود
وشبه جزيره القرم كما نقلت رويترز عن حاكم
كورس الروسيه قوله ان هجوما اوكرانيا
بطائره مسيره على المدينه الحق اضرارا في
منازل ومبنى اداري اعلنت القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه اسقاطت 220 طائره و11 صاروخا
اطلقت روسيا الليله الماضيه وافاد الجيش
الاوكراني بان دفاعاته الجويه اعترضت تسع
عشر مسيره من نوع شاهد اطلقتها القوات
الروسيه باتجاه جنوب غربيه البلاد ليله
الماضيه اضاف ان قواته اعترضت احد عشر
صاروخا من اصل 12 من نوع كاليبر وقالت
مصادر محليه ان مخازن الحبوب في ميناء
واوديستا تعرضت لاضرار جسيمه جراء هذا
الهجوم
افاد الجيش الاوكراني بان قواته استهدفت
مواقع عده تابعه للقوات الروسيه على طول
جبهات القتال وبث الجيش الاوكراني وصورا
قال انها لقواته خلال تمشيط في عمليه في
بلده كلشيفكا على محور بخموت في اقليم
الدومباس وكان الجيش الاوكراني اعدل
سيطرته على هذه البلده الاسبوع الماضي
نحن من زبروجيا مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام
الياس مرحبا بك بين ما تعلنه ما تعلنه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن اسقاط طائرات
قصيره اوكرانيه وكذلك الهجوم الذي يعلنه
ايضا وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه اين تتركز هذه الهجمات
الهجوم الكبير حقيقه طال هذا اليوم منطقه
اوديسا منطقه المدينه وكذلك تحديدا
الميناء البحري على اوديس الهجوم كان
هجوما كبيرا والوسائط الدفاعيه الاوكرانيه
اشتغلت بشكل كثيف بحسب الصور الوارده من
المدينه الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه تقول
بانها تمكنت من اعتراض احد عشر صاروخا من
نوع كليبر من اصل 12 صاروخا اطلقت باتجاه
اوديسا وباتجاه الاقليم
والوسائط الدفاعيه فشلت في اعتراض صاروخين
اطلق باتجاه الميناء يبدو انهما من نوع
الصواريخ المائيه البحريه الموجهه ضد
السفن وهذان الصاروخان يبدو انهما احدثا
دمارا كبيرا في الميناء تحديدا في
مستودعات الحبوب في ميناء اوديسا بالاضافه
الى دمار كبير
في احد المباني الشاهقه القريبه من
الميناء ويبدو ان هذا المكان او هذا
المبنى كان خاليا تماما من النزلاء عدا عن
ذلك الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه تقول
بانها اعترضت تسعه عشره مسيره مفخخه كانت
متجهه صوب اوديسا وصوب الميناء واعترضتها
بالكامل هذا بالاضافه الى ثلاث طائرات
هجوميه كانت اعتراضتها بالامس واربع
طائرات من النوع التكتيكي التابع للقوات
الروسيه هذا الهجوم على اوديسيا ربما يكون
هجوما ترد فيه القوات الروسيه على الهجمات
المنسوبه لاوكرانيا والتي اعترفت فيها في
الايام الاخيره والتي استهدفت قواعد
عسكريه للقوات الروسيه في شبه جزيره القرم
وباهمها بطبيعه الحال مقر اسطول البحر
الاسود وكذلك الهجمات التي طرفت فيها
اوكرانيا
بالتوجيه ضربات لمعسكر ساكي هذه القاعده
الجويه التي تستخدم من قبل القوات الروسيه
لضرب العمق الاوكراني وبالتالي هذا الهجوم
الواسع الذي استهدف اوديسا اليوم وياتي
اولا كما يبدو للرد على هذه الهجمات التي
طالت شبه جزيره القرن في الايام الماضيه
وايضا استمرارا لسياسه روسيا في الاسابيع
الماضيه في استهداف موانئ اوديسا واسماعيل
وريني على نهر الدانوب هذه الموانئ التي
تحاول اوكرانيا من خلالها
استحداث ربما ممر بحري امن من اجل تصدير
الحبوب الى دول العالم بعد فشل او اخفاق
الاتفاق الموقع بين اوكرانيا وروسيا وخروج
روسيا من هذا الاتفاق كانت هنالك
استهدافات عديده من قبل القوات الروسيه في
الاسابيع الماضيه لميناء اوديسيا واسماعيل
وريني على والهدف من ذلك هو وضع حد لهذا
الممر البحري او ايقاف ايه حركه للسفن عبر
هذا الممر الامن التي تحاول اوكرانيا
انجازه في البحر الاسود وعبر الدانوب من
اجل تصدير الحبوب عاد عن ذلك القوات
الاوكرانيه تقول بان عملياتها الهجوميه
مستمره على محورين اساسيين المحور الاول
في منطقه الشرق حيث محور ضخمه القوات
الاوكرانيه تقول بانها تموضعت وتمركزت عند
المواقع التي وصلت اليها في الايام
الاخيره وهي ما زالت تصدها هجمات للقوات
الروسيه التي تحاول اعاده السيطره على
مواقعها التي فقدتها في كليشيفكا
واندريفيكا وغيرها من المواقع هناك
والهجوم الابرز الهجوم الرئيسي المتواصل
هنا على محور زبروجيا جنوبا حيث يقول
الجيش الاوكراني بانه يواصل هجومه نحو
ويحرس تقدما على محوري برفيفيه وراكوتين
لكن بالاضافه الى ذلك قوات الروسيه تجن في
تشن في الايام الاخيره هجمات على الخطوط
الخلفيه للقوات الاوكرانيه المتقدمه على
هذا المحور
وتوجهه ضربات للخطوط الخلفيه للجيش
الاوكراني في اوريخوف وفي غيرها من
البلدات الاوكرانيه التي اصبحت في الايام
الماضيه اشبه بخط مواجهه مباشر في هذا
القتال المستمر القوات الاوكرانيه تتطلع
حاليا الى التقدم على هذا المحور للوصول
الى بلده تقمق الواقعه الى الجنوب من
الروبوتين وترفيه هذه البلده التي تقول
القوات الاوكرانيه بانها سقطت عسكريا على
اعتبار انها اصبحت في مرمى النيران
الاوكرانيه وان القوات الروسيه بدات
تتراجع عن هذا المحور والتوقعات انه فيما
اذا تمكنت القوات الاوكرانيه من السيطره
على توبماك وهي بلده مهمه على الطريق
السريعه المؤدي الى
اندفاع القوات الاوكرانيه سيكون سريعا في
الايام المقبله ربما في الاسابيع المقبله
نحو الهدف الرئيسي لهذه العمليه هنا في
المنطقه الجنوبيه لزبولوجيا وهو محاوله
القوات الاوكرانيه الوصول الى مدينه
مولوتوبول عقده المواصلات المهمه التي
تقطع الامدادات الروسيه من جهه الشرق الى
اخرسون والى شبه جزيره القرم وتقرب القوات
الاوكرانيه خطوه كبيره جدا نحو المناطق
الشماليه للقرض شكرا جزيلا